- YEAH, WHAT'S UP, AMERICA?
I'M SAM.I.AM.
- THIS YOUR BOY SCUBA.
- I'M LEMON LIME.
- WE ABOUT TO DROP SOME
SERIOUS RHYMES ON YOUR MIND.
♪ THIS IS A REVOLUTION,
BRING DOWN THE INSTITUTION ♪
♪ POLLUTION-PRODUCING
COLLUSION ♪
♪ UNCLE SAM, WE WANT YOU
FOR EXECUTION ♪
♪ FREE YOUR MIND,
FREE YOUR MIND, FREE YOUR MIND ♪
- ♪ ON THE STREETS,
BUT WE OWN OUR BEATS ♪
- YO, BEATS & RICE, WHAT'S UP?
I'M JASON, MAN.
I'VE BEEN CHECKING YOU GUYS OUT
ON THE INTERNET.
UNBELIEVABLE STUFF.
I WANT TO GET YOU GUYS
ON MY LABEL HERE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
- OKAY.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA CHANGE
THE MESSAGE, THOUGH, RIGHT?
- I'M NOT GONNA CHANGE
THE MESSAGE--YOU KIDDING ME?
THE MESSAGE IS THE KEY. HEY,
LISTEN, SWEETHEART, COME HERE.
I WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO SOMEBODY.
THIS IS LADY D.I.Y.
SHE'S GONNA BE YOUR NEW SINGER.
OKAY, WHY DON'T YOU GUYS
GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER.
EVERYBODY, WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A LOT OF FUN.
EVERYBODY GET UP THERE.
OKAY, SCUBA!
- ♪ FREE YOUR MINUTES
♪ ALL YOUR CELL PHONE
MINUTES ♪
♪ YOU GOT TO GO CHANGE
YOUR PLAN ♪
♪ IT'S TIME FOR YOU
TO TAKE A STAND ♪
all three: ♪ SAM.I.AM,
LEMON LIME, SCUBA ♪
- ♪ Y'ALL KNOW WHO I AM
- ♪ IT'S TIME TO SWITCH UP
YOUR CELLULAR PLAN ♪
- ♪ TYRANNY IN CONTRACTS
♪ DIFFERENT PLANS
KEEPING ME DOWN ♪
- ♪ LOSE THE SERVICE, MAN,
I LOOK LIKE A CLOWN ♪
- ♪ IT'S TIME WE ALL
COME TOGETHER ♪
♪ AND GET THE BEST PLAN
WE EVER HAD ♪
all: CHINA, AFRICA, USA,
GERMANY ♪
- ♪ RESTRICTIONS APPLY
ON ALL CALLS OVERSEAS ♪
♪
- ALL RIGHT, GREAT SHOW, GUYS.
GREAT SHOW.
LISTEN, I GOT A GREAT WAY
TO MAKE SOME EASY MONEY.
I'M TALKING ABOUT GETTING
IN THE BIG-BOX STORES.
- BUT WHAT ABOUT OUR MESSAGE?
- THE MESSAGE--
I'M TALKING ABOUT COMBINING
THIS SEX HERE WITH FITNESS.
OKAY? THAT'S WHY, LISTEN,
I HAD TO GET RID
OF LEMON LINE, ALL RIGHT?
THIS IS REMON RYE.
- HI. I'M A CHRISTIAN
MINISTER.
- ALL RIGHT, NOW, LET'S GO
MAKE SOME MONEY, GUYS. COME ON!
AND HAVE SOME FUN TOO,
ALL RIGHT?
- ♪ FREE YOUR BODY RIGHT
- ♪ FAT FREE, Y'ALL
- ♪ FREE YOUR BODY TONIGHT
♪ YEAH, YEAH
- ♪ SIT-UPS, PUSH-UPS,
WORKING THE CORE ♪
- ♪ BITCH IT, PERCH IT
- ♪ DANCE LIKE A WHORE
♪ STAY HYDRATED
♪ ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR DEMONS
- THE MONEY'S GONE.
WE ARE IN THE RED.
THE MANSION'S FORECLOSED.
WE HAVE DRUG PROBLEMS
ALL AROUND THE TABLE.
EVERYBODY'S ON THE HORSE.
EVERYBODY, INCLUDING MYSELF.
BUT WE HAVE AN UNTAPPED MARKET.
I'M TALKING ABOUT KIDS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE LITTLE ONES.
- YEAH, BUT WHAT'S THE MESSAGE?
- THE MESSAGE IS HIT THE KIDS
WHERE IT COUNTS.
IT'S A CASH GRAB, OKAY?
IT'S AS MUCH CASH
AS WE CAN GRAB.
- ♪ FREE YOUR POOPIES
- ♪ WHEN I SAY POO,
YOU SAY POO ♪
all: ♪ POO POO, DOO DOO
♪ SIT ON THE CAN,
WE KNOW YOU CAN ♪
♪ DON'T BELIEVE ME?
ASK SPACE BABY ♪
- ♪ NO DOODIES
IN THE BATHTUB
- ♪ PEE IN THE POTTY
- ♪ TELL YOUR MOM AND DAD
WHEN YOU HAVE TO GO ♪
- ♪ WE JUST PULLED OVER
♪ HOW COME YOU DIDN'T TELL US
WHEN YOU HAD TO GO? ♪
- ♪ 'CAUSE I DIDN'T HAVE
TO GO THEN ♪
- ♪ GO, SPACE BABY,
GO, SPACE BABY ♪
♪ GO, GO, GO, SPACE BABY
- WHAT'S THE MESSAGE?
[fireworks whistling]
- ♪ YOU'RE A BIG BOY NOW
[explosion]
- WHA--WHAT HAPPENED?